hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the personality test now
if you know there are certain like
categories of personality that can be
divided into certain individual
qualities some are opposing some are
complimentary to each other and each of
them outlines into these four
overarching categories each with four
subcategories now this is not fact this
is obviously an idea it's the theory of
how to categorize people personalities
but at the same time everybody's
personality is going to be slightly
different from person person even if
they fall in one of these categories
uh you guys seem to want to know what
kind of person I am I'm going to answer
this quiz for you and thankfully there's
no punishment for getting it wrong and I
don't have to make a bet so that's good
to get started it takes less than 12
minutes you got to answer honestly so
I'm going to be answering as honestly as
I possibly can and then I'm not gonna do
any neutral answers
there will be no neutrality here it's
all going to be 100% me and my test
number one you find it difficult to
introduce yourself to other people does
hello everybody when I shout it to the
entire internet count as introducing
myself because I'm pretty sure I got
that down on lock please don't show how
many times I have to redo my interest
hello everybody hello everybody hello
everybody hello everybody hello
everybody
now I'm good you often get so lost in
thought that you ignore or forget your
surroundings ah I have a TD which means
that I get a little Spacey sometimes but
not so much that I forget my
surroundings I have a certain level of
clutter that I'm comfortable with and I
think it's only acceptable because I
forget it but this doesn't happen too
often so I'd say it's not neutral just
yeah yeah that's probably right you try
to respond to your emails as soon as
possible and cannot stand a messy inbox
huh no no no it'll be weeks before I get
back to some people even my best friends
I'll text him two days later so sorry
I'm bad about that you find it easy to
stay relaxed and focused even when
there's some pressure
yeah actually I'm great under pressure I
were
better under pressure than I do without
pressure because with pressure
I have deadlines and with like the
eagerness to get something done - like
really show that I can do it that helps
me stay focused it is awesome
you do not usually initiate
conversations that actually is me I may
be bombastic and you know exclamatory at
times but I usually don't say the first
word when it comes to people I don't
reach out to my friends and text them on
a regular basis and that maybe you like
me might be going well I can't even
fathom that checking in on your friends
is like a regular thing but it's not to
me it's just not something I think about
it it's something that takes a lot of a
lot of mental effort to actually do so I
gotta go with I agree on that one I'm an
introvert like honestly I'm an introvert
so this is me you rarely do something
out of sheer curiosity Oh Bob I'm always
curious I I do everything out of sheer
curiosity got any other qualities you
feel superior to other people what me
whatever the way okay being organized is
more important to you than being
adaptable Oh adaptable is everything
it's the only thing it's everything I've
got
you're usually highly motivated and
energetic usually sorry Burpee sorry
does that count is motivated and
energetic winning the debate matters
less to you than making sure no one gets
upset ah I usually like to play the
mediator in those situations I love a
good debate but usually I don't want to
like go out of my way to make sure that
someone's upset I mean naturally in
debate that's gonna happen so I don't
mind that but you know there's always
common ground to be found so I'd go with
this disagree that level of disagree you
often feel as if you have to justify
yourself to other people no god I never
need to justify my actions I mean I may
apologize for them and acknowledge the
weirdness of my actions but I won't
justify it
it's just be your home and work
environments are good normal
no no no no no no no no no no the
opposite no way way wrong of that you do
not mind being at the center of
attention yeah I don't mind it kind of
happened right now with all of you
looking at me incessantly you consider
yourself more practical than creative
[Music]
I'm pretty practical but at the same
time what I do is create no actually now
that's that complete bollocks I am all
about practicality I am I am minimalist
to tease so that's that crime people can
rarely upset you agree in all honesty
what gets said to me very rarely upsets
me people can say whatever they want
about me people can not like my videos
people can not like me as a person I
won't care I literally couldn't give a
[ __ ] but if it's my friends talking it's
my friends giving me advice or my
friends saying something that does hurt
my feelings that could hurt my feelings
because obviously I trust their opinion
so if they're saying something that's
negative towards me then I'm like well
[ __ ] maybe I'm wrong maybe I'm an
[ __ ]
I got a rethink about this so that's
usually how that goes but it rarely you
try out your travel plans should usually
move just booking a flight the day prior
count as well thought out does packing
my suitcase as I'm running out the door
count as well thought out I don't think
so it is often difficult for you to
relate to other people's feelings no I
am I'm excessively empathetic like I
really really God I'm really empathetic
I may not like again I'm Spacey but at
the same time like when there's
something I feel for like I really feel
for and your mood can change very
quickly
I usually easily takes a lot to get me
from A to B so oh dis agree sorry in a
discussion true should be more important
than people's sensitivities oh god yeah
truth in all things truth truth matters
every above everything you rarely worry
about how your actions affect other
people no I worry I worry a lot about
what I do and how they affect people
yeah I got to go with disagree on that
one your work style is closer to random
energy spikes than a methodical yeah
yeah that's the one that's the
randomness and the energy that's me
you're often envious of others
your all your your nothing envious of
new Oilers um not really
no I'm pretty happy where I am I'm
pretty happy with what I have them I'm
pretty happy with who I am so I don't
find the purpose in being envious of
other people okay I got what I got and
I'm lucky to have it so and everyone
else has what they have and they may
have more or less but you know I'm
content with what I got and who I an
interesting book or video game is often
better than as a hoe being able to
develop a plan and stick to it is the
most important part of every project yes
this is something that I've actually
learned recently because it used to be I
appreciate improvisation above anything
else and I love improv comedy and I love
making stuff up on the fly but also I've
learned that the the better part of
making a project come true is having a
nice plan so I'm going to go with it's
against my nature but I'm learning so
I'll go with this little squid right
there you rarely get a carried away by
fantasies on the ideas and I idea and
fantasize all the time
you often find yourself lost in thought
when you're walking in nature oh hell
yeah if someone does not respond to your
email quickly you start worrying if you
said something wrong now I never say
anything wrong what could I say it's me
they're talking to how bad could it
possibly be
mmm II know I I just I assume they're
like me and don't get back to people as
a parent you'd rather your child grow up
kind than smart does it have to be a
choice I want him to be smart I guess
but kind is good too but what if they're
an evil genius that might be it might be
kind of cool maybe that's a dumb
question that's a dumb question
[Music]
the way I see it my way too smart my way
through it is that if they are they are
smart maybe they'd figure out being kind
all on their own I don't I'm assuming
this mean they're either smart and an
[ __ ] or kind and kind of dumb
I'll go smart yeah I'd rather see smart
you do not let other people influence
your actions I'm pretty bullheaded
I will readily admit I am bullheaded to
a tee it's like I uh I have an idea and
I want to do that and I want to commit
to it and it's hard for me to deviate
from that I'm learning there's no way I
can convince that learning like I don't
know in a grand scheme of things I'm
pretty steadfast in what I want to do so
if I was being honest with the quiz and
honest who I am and even though I've
learned to appreciate the input of
others like I'm confident in in my
action so that's that's me your dreams
tend to focus on real word of world and
it's events yeah pretty much it's never
really really fantasy stuff except with
nightmares those are I guess there's a
real world stuff anyway it does not take
you much time to start getting involved
in social ago you're more of a natural
improviser than a careful plan yep your
emotions control you more than you
control that man you enjoy going to
social events that involve dress up or
roleplay activities I've never done that
in my life I've never gone to a roleplay
social dress up orgy no that's not
something I've done but I want oh that
sounds awesome why wouldn't I do that I
love it there was one time when we were
having a Halloween party back in college
and I was the only one that dressed up
don't know what kind of Halloween party
guy bad goes here that they don't dress
up so I was just it's [ __ ] when the
Dark Knight was released and I was the
only one in uh and the hidden the Joker
in the nurse costume because everyone
was the Joker that year anyway it's not
important you often spend time exploring
unrealistic and in practice yeah I'm
gonna go back to that story because it
was really funny because I was I was
carrying in a box of beer or something
into into my friend's house and I was
knocking on the back door I was like
they were all in there and I was like
knock knock hey my arms fall can you up
and down
can can I can't do it and they were just
all staring me like because the [ __ ]
Joker was at their backdoor and they
didn't know it's me and none of them
address up so I just looked like there's
a freak as a Joker trying to get into
their little party and then my friends
finally let me in it made fun of me
literally all night and those that's
good times good times that's good you
often spend time exploring unrealistic
and impractical yet intriguing ideas
yeah I guess yeah I'm all for a good
impractical thing so I don't know why
not
I'm good me you would rather improvise
and spend time coming up with a detailed
plan wasn't it that's that question
that's the same question that's the same
gresham you are relatively reserved and
quiet person actually this is true my
base nature I've learned to like it like
a lot of things I've learned to come out
of shell but when it comes down to the
base person underneath like I'm actually
very reserved I'm very quiet I like my
peace and calm I like I'm not shouting
24/7 so I completely agree if you had a
business you would find it very
difficult to fire loyal but
underperforming employees yeah I would
actually got it because I have a
business technically I have employees so
it's yeah I just I don't think I could
do that you often contemplate the
reasons for human existence I don't
really I don't think it matters like I
well I mean like it matters in the grand
scheme of things but to me my personal
experience in this world like it'll
carry on whether I know the answer or
not like whether I have an answer
doesn't change the fact that I'm here
still constrained by the rules you know
what I mean the rules of universe and
you can bend the rules and maybe we can
come up with technology to change the
rules but until that point comes
why bother worrying about it I mean sure
pursue the truth pursue the truth in all
things find out the reason if you really
can find out the reason but
in the meantime don't let it give you an
existential crisis logic is usually more
important than heart when it comes to
making important decisions agree keeping
your options open is more important than
having a to-do list agree if your friend
is sad about something you are more
likely to offer emotional support than
suggest a way to deal with the problem I
know I'm a fixer I'm a fixer I like
fixing things I mean I'm there for
emotional support but I'm a fixer I'm a
hundred percent of fixer you rarely feel
insecure yeah you have no difficulties
coming up with a personal timetable ooh
being right is more important than being
cooperative when it comes to teamwork no
cooperate you think that everybody's
view should be respected regardless of
whether they are supported by facts or
not nope facts matter you feel more
energetic after spending time with a
group of people oh that's like the basis
of my introversion like I I cannot I
can't get energy from other people I
can't I get energy from being by myself
and alone and doing my own things with
my own thoughts I have to I have to be
there you really miss laser things agree
you see yourself as a very emotionally
stable agree your mind is always buzzing
with unexplored ideas and plans agree
you would not call yourself a dreamer
I'm a dreamer I'm a dreamer I'm
definitely a dreamer very lofty goals
and lofty things that I want to
accomplish in life and walk the ideas
for the world that I'm a dreamer you
usually find it difficult to relax when
talking in front of many people
no oddly enough even though I'm an
introvert I'm very good at talking
I am ludicrously good at talking I'm
great in social situations when I put my
mind to it but it's not my base nature
but oddly enough being on stage and
talking in front of a whole crowd of
people I actually find enjoyable like I
don't know what it is it I think it's
just a difference between talking to a
whole bunch of people and then talking
to people on an individual level when I
have to talk to people and get to know
I'm good at that but it's not my
favorite thing to do you know I love
being an on-stage
and I love making videos knowing that
there's a whole bunch of people watching
like I get energy from that I really do
I love it but it's like the
interpersonal
stuff like that that's where my
introvert nature comes to life like
that's really where it is and it's not
like I don't want to do it I want to
meet people I want to do that I want to
meet you guys on an individual level but
when it comes to that I don't get energy
from it
I just don't it has to I have to spend
energy to do that and I think that's the
key difference in an introvert and
extrovert but also speaking in front of
people is something that comes very
natural to me and I enjoy it a great
deal so ah now I'm good at that I know I
don't find it never journals begin you
rely more on your experience in your
imagination not it doesn't matter if you
have experience because if you can
imagine yourself where you want to be
then at least you have a road to get
there and then your willpower can take
you the rest of the way so I don't have
a lot of experience in a lot of things I
do but I I believe that I can and
sometimes that's all you need you worry
too much about what other people they
can think whatever they want to think
who cares if the room is full you stay
closer to the walls avoiding the center
I usually just find wherever there's a
comfortable seat depends on the room too
so let's imagine some room like a house
party there's a bunch of people
everywhere but there's no furniture
let's just make that assumption in this
weird imagination world that is my house
and then oh I actually actually know
this weird this is made me realize I
like standing in social situations I'm a
stander so I like standing but not
against the wall I like standing let
right in the middle and it's not for any
like sake of being the center of
attention I just like standing where
there's the most space and I will pick
that space and whether that's the center
of the wall I have no idea
so I disagree on this you have a
tendency to procrastinate until it's not
attentive to every
you feel very anxious in stressful
situations now again great in stressful
situations I love it I love being in
stressful situations it motivates me to
no end you believe that it's more
rewarding to be liked by others than to
be powerful that's a good question
because I believe powerful in the sense
what is that even mean but I'm going to
assume that means influential or you
know can command respect or something to
that effect now you can you can have
power and you can be liked but I'm
assuming this means that you have power
and you're not like or you're liked and
have no power so in my all honest like
state I don't really mind if people
don't like me
like I get that because I like me I like
I like Who I am and I like what I'm
doing and sometimes I get bogged down
and I get sad and I question where I'm
going but that's only because I'm really
waiting and looking in on myself and
seeing if I'm in the place I want to be
and if I'm not I change that so I guess
I would have to by my nature say that I
find it's more rewarding to be powerful
I guess not that I crave power but just
because the opposite the answer isn't
true so you've always been interested in
unconventional and ambiguous things eg
in books art or movies wait that's not
unconventional that's not unconventional
I mean yeah
I like me some good books and movies and
I can appreciate me some good art Modern
Art I'm on the fence of but you know I
can appreciate it and I guess I
gravitate towards those things and video
games with the medium you know yeah I
guess I could do yeah I could say that
if you call those on and conventional
and ambiguous you often take the
initiative in social situations ah again
here's where my weird nature comes in
because if it's a social situation where
I need to take the initiative like a
convention or a meet-and-greet with you
guys or a panel I gladly take center
stage I will do that and I'll be there
I'll make introductions if I'm in a
meeting I'm gonna be the first one to
try to remember everybody's name shake
everyone's hand because I like giving
off a good impression
and that overcomes my nature of wanting
to be an entry so like my desires
overtake certain nature's and each one
will play a different role in different
situations so I would I would take the
innocent and with that that is the last
question and therefore we're ready for
an answer
you all ready to be astonished by what
is in the super scientific survey of
epic proportions and here we go BAM
I'm a debater I'm a debater deeper dirt
did Badou I don't know what that means
I'm a debater which is an intp - eh uh
it means that I'm it I like this because
I like this because it ranks your
extroversion and introversion because I
think we all need certain levels of
social situations we need certain levels
of isolation time and so you know they
vary from person person to person we
direct our mental energy towards the
intuitive or the observance so I I get a
lot of my energy I guess from my mind I
come up with my ideas and then my nature
is very much thinking but still feeling
like I do feel like it's not like I am
completely numb to what other people
think or like what I feel because
obviously you guys know this from all
the crying videos I have put on my
channel here but you know I'm very I'm
very logically organ in it I've always
said tactics yep I'm bad at planning and
pretty sure that's all that what it is I
don't plan I just make it up as I go
along and then identity I'm a hundred
percent assertive a hundred brute I'm a
hundred percent I kid I'm 97 percent I
don't have a plan 90 90 97 percent of
the time but I'm a hundred percent of
sort of how dare you
how let me point out why you're wrong
about that I am the least observers
laughs yeah they're right I don't know
what that means anything oh here we go
follow the path of the unsafe
independent thinker expose your ideas to
the dangers of controversy speak our
mind and fear less the label of crackpot
than the stigma of conformity non issues
that seem important to you stand up and
be counted
at any cost I don't know what this means
anyway the ultimate devil's advocate oh
boy they're having on the process of
shedding arguments and to belief in
letting the ribbons drift in this win
for all the sea an object's deposition
arises with debaters as their
uncompromising lis honest but will argue
tirelessly for something they don't
actually build what stepping into
another shoes to argue a truth from
another perspective oh okay I get it so
that just means that I that debaters not
me particularly would see the problem
from another perspective even if even if
I'm wrong and that's true like even if
I'm wrong I want to make sure you know I
like even if I think I'm right and I'm
actually wrong I want to make sure that
I'm right and I would you know see the
counterpoint of that there are no rules
here we're trying to accomplish
something taking a certain pleasure in
being the underdog debaters enjoy the
mental exercise in questioning the
prevailing mode of thought making them
irreplaceable in reworking existing
systems or shaking things up and pushing
them in new clever new directions
however they'll be miserable managing
the day-to-day mechanics of actually
implementing their suggestions ah that
me that sounds like me maybe okay
alright then what's my with my weird al'
Adam Savage Sarah Silverman mark twain
great Tom Hanks cool this is a whole
grab bag all the Joker it's all fate it
makes sense that's it look it I was the
Joker Halloween there is kind of suck
you know what the [ __ ] the test for
these not real characters [ __ ] does that
mean
I don't know hey but hey I'm with the
Joker I guess so that's good it's my
strengths and weaknesses what they'll
like ah cool all right cool what's my
weaknesses argumentative oh maybe I
don't dare you I'm not a humanity
insensitive god no I'm not
I'm a little insensitive this is a bunch
of [ __ ] this is a load of garbo
that's it this this is a bunch of
[ __ ] all right let's see your career
paths if engineers on here I'm gonna be
pissed
bibbidi boom bah buh buh buh not every
career allows this level of unbridled
brain power yeah oh yeah that's me all
right
mmm delegate lucky little bit good bill
the conclusion let's just get a glitters
get it all out there debaters
intelligence curiosity and sound
reasoning skills are a force to be
reckoned with debaters will always be
able to find just the right argument the
weakest chenkin now opponents of armor
or the way out of a seemingly hopeful
hopeless situation their fearsome debate
skills and impressive knowledge allowed
two betas they overcome many I think
this is flattering me at this point I'm
not a hundred percent sure that this is
true here but whatever I guess yet
debaters can be easily tripped up in
areas where careful and rational
thinking is more of a liability than an
asset what fine huh [ __ ] you take some
of this take my entp guns here and [ __ ]
them up your ass alright anyway I guess
I'm all done here you may have muttered
to yourself wow this is so accurate it's
a little creepy or finally someone
understands me how do they know more
more about me than the people I'm closes
- yeah whatever okay all right you're
writing some spots you're wrong in some
other spots which is probably what it
don't Pater would say an n-tuple a
whatever good anyway that's uh me I
guess so I don't know if that's true or
not but it is what it says it is so you
want to take this for yourself again
take the results with a grain of salt
like I said in the test I went by what
my base nature is but I've learned
things to escape that and I've changed
over time so if I took this year or if I
took this quiz like five years ago it
probably completely different results
because I wouldn't have had the
experience of being a youtuber and
talking to you guys and learning from
you guys
and getting those experiences in my own
personnel because you know we change
people do people change hopefully for
the better sometimes for the worse
but people change and you can learn
different skills so if I were to answer
this based on what I think I am now it
might be different from what I actually
am and who knows what you actually are a
test isn't going to tell that life
experience going away thank you
everybody so much for watching upload a
link to this quiz down the comments
below description below I was right the
whole time
and let me know what you think let me
know what kind of personality you are
I'd love to hear just in five letters
what kind of personality you're
boiled-down do and thank you everybody
so much for watching and as always I
will see you in the next video
[Music]